nous allons vous conter l'histoire les
aventures des aventures nous allons vous
conter l'histoire les aventures de
on n'a pas
le lou se fâche cette fois ne veut faire
un saut
venables croyez
hello
tout ce qui
trois mois savez vous que je connais au
delà de cette laie qui ferme l'enclos
une troupe doit bien grasse elle
pourrait facilement être à nous
peut-être est-elle bien gardés au juste
par un paysan g court vite et si je peux
rapporter une ou deux nous pourrons
cette fois allé manger ensemble
[Musique]
cette fois son électro renard voile
assez longtemps que tu te moques de moi
tu comptais bien sûr le sien pour me
faire déchirer
ça s'est mise en gras vous savez bien
que vous êtes le plus fort n'en abusez
pas kg à me plaindre au roi et puis si
vous me tuez vous serez jugés et
condamnés à mort disant grain avant de
mourir
recevez ma dernière confession je jure
que je n'ai jamais cherché à vous nuit
ici renard n'avait vraiment rien à se
reprocher bon je te laisse en vie
l'histoire je te pardonne alors il faut
m'en faire serment comme tu vaux droit
je suis prêt à le jurer sur les saintes
reliques barbe et venez avec moi je
connais une église non loin d'ici un
saint martin repose près du porche vous
pourrez faire votre serment sur sa tombe
au nom de tous les bienheureux de celui
qui reposent ici je jure de ne garder
aucun ressentiment envers renard or mien
il en grains passant par là
on joue à moi or voilà pris très peu
parlé contre la pensée lui un parjure le